moi aussi gros d'accord véhicules d'alimentation interne
maintenant sur alimentation interne vous pouvez voir la
première tour ombilicale rétractée mm d'accord
approbation sociale effrontée magna la
popularité si glissante nous avons dit Djibouti
le vqd pour activer la séquence automatique
initiée
la séquence automatique est initiée cette deuxième
tour se rétracte maintenant dix  secondes depuis les
moteurs de lancement ont commencé et sont maintenant
au niveau de poussée préliminaire
étranglement et décollage dont nous avons le
décollage et MacLean pour battre Saint
Jacques et Oleg Kononenko explosant à
travers le ciel kazakh jusqu'à la
Station spatiale internationale
tout semble bon jusqu'à présent bonne
performance de première étape  ou utiliser
fournir neuf cent trente mille
livres de poussée
30 secondes dans tout a toujours l'air
bien, le premier étage brûlera pendant deux
minutes les deux premières minutes et six
secondes du vol est nominal pour le
paramètre, alors bombardez les nouvelles de Cisco, c'est pour
endurcir mal don '  t en le poussant vers le haut,
tout ce qui a l'air bien, le véhicule est
stable à la première étape, la performance du
ve  hicle parcourt maintenant plus de 1 100 miles
par heure
quatre-vingts secondes toutes les pharmacies sont
nominales une minute 30 secondes et est un
vol tout a toujours l'air bien
la scène brûlera à nouveau pour le FIR
jusqu'à 1 minute 58 secondes dans le
vol et vous verrez ces quatre
sangle  -sur les boosters larguent Guji donc
Phoebe Amidon aquel caso comb design le
second était un Diwali a gardé son éditeur
à ce moment-là à eu de la chance XE peut alors
je peux être dans la tour d'évasion a été
largué et ces quatre
boosters à sangle ont également largué ils ont
terminé leur travail et tomberont
à une altitude de 28 milles